I mean having six women that everyday
because of violence I mean that's just
crazy this can't be happening
I think the main issue is the silence so
my inspiration for this piece is to stop
being quiet about it
so when somebody dies the police comes
and they put tape around a body so this
is my way to say the women are here
while I was painting it but I was
feeling very very sad and upset so if I
did feel that way maybe some people
passing by it would get to kill it too
there's this girl looking at the white
signs Popo wishing expecting the world
to change the violence to stop projects
like this remind people that this is
going on that is not okay that you
should care and that there are ways to
change this reality
you